hello how are you good morning i'm a
little sleepy you're sleepy well we can
wake right up what's up what's going on
with home sales sales of existing homes
in may dropped 3.4 percent to a
seasonally adjusted annualized rate of
for 5.41 million units uh basically
sales were 8.6
lower than in may 2021. this is the
weakest reading since june of 2020 in
the beginning of the pandemic you know
why
because
of
uh interest rates
in the same inflation oop too slow
they make cost of capital expensive
if it's expensive people don't borrow if
people don't borrow they don't got the
cash to buy the home on top of that
whenever there's uncertainty in the
economic environment a lot of people say
hey don't rock the boat let's not try to
move let's not try to go get a new job
in a new city let's not try like just
stay where you are shelter in place you
ever hear that yeah i don't know if uh
in georgia they had uh tornado warnings
or hurricane warnings sheltered and
mentioned shelter in place shelter in
the staircase right that's they used to
do the uh the tornado uh drills everyone
go on the staircase you try to find your
friends hallway education uh the whole
idea is shelter in place that's what
people do when a recession is coming you
do when a hurricane's coming when a
tornado is coming and when a recession
is coming you shelter in place which
means you're not moving means that there
isn't as much demand to buy homes then
on top of that you are trying to
get any sort of capital they made it
more expensive the whole idea of raising
interest rates and making capital more
expensive they call it demand
destruction
the reason why they call it demand
destruction is because they are
literally destroying the demand which is
exactly why you see less borrowing which
is also why you see home sales going
down because the demand has been
destructed
and there will be a further decline
because the impact of higher mortgage
rates are not yet fully reflected in
this data so yeah the market is slow to
realize that yo mortgage rates were like
two and a half percent now they're like
five and a half percent
[ __ ] if you were searching for a home
you know back in january february and
now all of a sudden you pick up your
head and you're like oh i need to go get
my loan because i found my dream home
like cheat
more than 2x the cost of capital
oh no gotta go back to the calculator
hopefully i got a real one that works
what's up next with facial recognition
all right so microsoft is phasing out
its uh facial recognition technology it
says it's retiring it uh originally the
technology said it could infer emotions
as well as characteristics like age
gender and hair
obviously there was backlash so there
was privacy questions privacy concerns
discrimination all these things so now
microsoft is saying goodbye to the ai oh
that was good that was good
what do you think about this do you
agree or not agree well it's so
interesting that um
first of all i don't know why
that would be interesting to them other
than you know acquiring data from its
users
i think there's some woke stuff i don't
i don't think so i think it's okay first
of all says the guy who does not use his
facial recognition technology on his
phone i don't use it on my phone i don't
go in the amazon stores no i don't know
okay so how is that
um the reason that they're giving is uh
wokes though no i don't think so yeah
it's about i think it's privacy
uh i don't think so
what i think they're saying is that uh
the responsible use and this whole idea
of uh um discrimination etc and what
ends up happening from what i understand
in this space
is that if microsoft doesn't do it
somebody else is going to do it and so
instead
if you actually cared about this problem
you know what you would do no you would
be at the forefront of developing the
technology and setting the industry
standard for going ahead and being super
transparent and open sourcing the
algorithms the data all this stuff so
by retracting from the industry what you
do is you leave a vacuum for somebody
else to come in
who we may not be anywhere near
as able to pressure them into providing
the information as a technology company
why does microsoft need to know my
emotions based on my facial expressions
what do they need to know if i'm sad or
happy or sleepy well
an easy example would be take don't use
microsoft as an example first use an
egregious example if facebook
knew that you were happy or sad and they
could change the ads that they showed
you that would lead to a better
experience now what most people would
say is like oh you're violating my
privacy whatever have you ever
seen an ad in an uh feed like if you're
on twitter and all of a sudden like uh
you let's say that um i was on twitter
and i was scrolling and also and i got a
ad for uh uh
pregnant moms
i'd be like the [ __ ] is it like like
it's like a jarring experience right
you'd be like yo just show me the ad
that like fits what i want but that's
what people don't uh recognize is that
if there's going to be ads you actually
want good targeting in the ads because
it ends up being relevant to you now you
could make the argument that actually i
just don't want ads that's fine you make
that argument but if there are ads you
want them to have the ability to target
you well and so the holy grail would be
hey improve your targeting but also
protect my privacy also protect my data
and so what microsoft here would end up
doing is they're
collecting more data but if you're
worried about microsoft doing facial
recognition don't use your iphone don't
walk down the street if you're in new
york city guess what there's facial
recognition everywhere with my point
being that like one company retracting
doesn't necessarily happen do you know
who else retracted yeah who the irs
the irs wanted to use facial
uh what is it
recognition technology to uh to help
with fraud prevention and help people
file their taxes online so
as an example there's a company in
crypto that i forget the name i
apologize uh but there are a number of
companies that use this technology if
you want to withdraw
funds off of some of these platforms
this company's pitches we helped to do
identity verification and in the user
flow when they demoed it uh is if i
remember correctly you have to upload uh
legal documentation so a passport or
license or some form of id front and
back or like the multiple pages of a
passport
then the camera pops up and it says put
your head in like this little hole and
then it makes you look left and right to
make sure that it's like a real person
and the reason why they're doing it is
for fraud prevention identity
verification etc and so in that
situation
there's many people who would say hey
it's worth having that technology
because there's a level of security the
question becomes can they protect the
information do they hold the data like
all of the other questions so i don't
think that
microsoft pulling out of doing this
actually solves the problem that like
the privacy uh proponents want because
you're not gonna get everyone to pull
out instead
don't celebrate they're pulling out
leaving a vacuum for someone else to
fill that we may may or may not have the
ability to use public shareholder
pressure instead get microsoft to set
the standard as to how every single
company should uh present this data open
source it make sure that we know it's
not being used incorrectly yeah all
right what's next jim cramer hi what's
up with jimmy chill
jim kramer has a message to young people
gen z 18 to 24 who
according to a recent deloitte survey
they say more than half of them say they
live paycheck to paycheck
jim cramer said you need to learn how to
be more frugal he said that you know
he's he's noticed younger customers at a
new york restaurant he owns spend money
quote unquote as if they grew on a tree
he's seen countless young professionals
buying round after round of 14
margaritas after a workday despite
hearing their complaints about student
loans or not having enough money to put
aside for retirement this is very
anecdotal jim what are your thoughts
i mean he has a point but it just it
sounds very much like get off my lawn
type of thing
he he said he lives on a form oh does he
really yeah as a farmer he bought fun
he bought his farm with the profits
after i convinced him to buy bitcoin he
goes well he goes i know you might say
oh kramer's rich i don't want to hear
this lecture but did you live in your
car on the side of interstate five so
he's talking about a period of time when
he was in his 20s living out of his car
so i don't think that people should go
and uh intentionally torpedo their life
quality in order to be frugal but what i
do think is that there's a healthy
balance yes do people spend money on
dumb things of course uh but that's not
just a young person thing if you look uh
at people across ages they spend money
on dumb things and what has happened is
that there has been a shift from high
quality goods to a now over consumption
type mentality in the united states
because the currency continues to be
devalued
if you know that the currency that
you're paid in is going to lose value
over time you are financially
incentivized to get rid of it how do you
get rid of it you either invest it or
you consume but if you leave it in your
bank account you lose and so in a period
over the last two years where 40 of all
dollars in circulation have been created
you now have people who are saying damn
i can't leave it in my bank account so
you know what i'm gonna do i'm either
going to invest it or i'm going to
consume
and so yes people are going to spend
money because they're financially
incentivized to do it the whole idea of
being frugal if you had left the money
sitting in your bank account might not
actually be better now the other thing i
will say is that there's a lot of folks
uh sounds like jim cramer's advocating
for this uh what's the woman susie orman
uh dave ramsey a bunch of these folks
they're always like don't spend money
don't spend money don't spend money
don't spend money don't go get the five
dollar coffee don't go get the five
dollar coffee
guess what
you are more likely to find a path to
creating 300 more of income per month
than most people are in cutting 300
monthly expenses if your monthly
expenses let's just say that uh you
don't make a lot of money and your
monthly expenses are twelve hundred
dollars
to cut three hundred dollars to cut
public math 25
of your monthly expenses
is harder than trying to go find a way
to make an extra 300 a month now it's
going to require you to work if there's
no you know uh uh fast lane to doing it
but it's easier to make more than it is
to cut net i actually think you're
in the minority of that opinion i think
that's a contrarian view i think most
people think it's easier to cut
something out than find a way to make
more money yeah they're wrong
how think about that take the dollar
figures out for a second and say to
somebody cut 25
of your monthly expenses
25 yeah it's a lot that changes that
changes your life in a major major way
how do i make more money it requires
effort it requires time it requires
ideas
again you got to do work you got to
actually say this is something that i
want to figure out
it doesn't just fall out of the sky
contrary to the socialist belief
but
it is easier to make 300 a month than it
is to cut 300 a month out of the average
citizen's budget i would love to see in
the chat if you guys can tell me how you
would make an extra 300 a month if you
didn't have to cut it i bet you i could
come up with right now five ways to make
three hundred dollars but i'm sure you
could you wanna you wanna know
literally go and go down the street
first thing i would do is i bet you that
you could go wash
car windows those guys who do the car
windows at stoplights they make a
killing really
of course they come they what's a bottle
of windex cost or whatever yeah but a
lot of people are squeegee it's like
you're in you're in business for 25
bucks
now all of a sudden no you don't need a
sponge you just get a squeegee and you
get some windex you roll up to someone's
car score squirt okay but a lot of
people don't give me ten dollars too bad
they just got their thing washed that's
how they make money give me the cash so
now they got their thing washed and then
you didn't get any money fine it did it
was it cost you two cents that was a two
cents
investment you do it enough times you
eventually get paid that's first
second thing you could do easy game is
you could easily go do do some math real
quick if you go to a local coffee shop
money mike said i would replace people's
fans light fixtures switches outlets and
cut grass easy i would hire you
immediately if you go on taskrabbit
taskrabbit if you know how to use power
tools you could be a gazillionaire on
taskrabbit there is nobody who
understands that stuff right then if you
also said
hold on then if you also said i'm
literally just going to not reinvent the
wheel i'm going to go cut grass yeah and
you went to the neighbors and you said
hey i'm going to spend
two saturdays a month
and i'm going to charge 30 bucks
i got to cut 10 grass that's five
on one saturday five on another there's
your three hundred dollars you're
talking about get your ass out of your
computer chair get out of your parents
but no i'm kidding not really a parent's
face
get out and do work and you can get
three hundred dollars so you're saying
physical labor it's how you would make
okay how about this
go to the literally this is i did this
actually when i was uh when i was 21
years old at one point i needed to make
some extra
i went to small businesses and i said yo
you need a website they're like yeah i
need a website all right cool i know how
to make a website they're like you know
how to code i was like i know how to
make a website don't worry you know how
to code i was like don't worry i know
how to make a website and uh they i said
to them i'll go build the website and
when i come back you'll be 500. they're
like all right whatever kid and i went
on wordpress and i built them a
wordpress site and then i went to the
businesses i was like you like the
website and they're like we love it i
was like cool give me my 500
wait you could do it on squarespace
today literally by the end of today you
have a bowling ass website you make 300
a day
yeah and you put the businesses online
but now we're in 2020 most of these
businesses are probably online you want
more ideas i got plenty of ideas
i'm just
300 let's go
so there is a city
that is going to be floating a floating
city they are building
big enough to house 20 000 people
uh it's in the maldives
and it's not because they want some like
wild experiment it's being built as a
practical solution to the rising uh sea
level yeah they all got to do this
really yeah of course this is so
interesting to me why
like it's just gonna float
yeah well i mean yeah they create it you
know when was it is it dubai
uh where they created the uh the palms
right i don't know yeah they built it
singapore
singapore was literally built
is it rising with the sea
singapore they were like do you see the
sea in front of us let's build land
there and they built land
and they grew it yeah of course they
grew the land that's what happened but
this is really literally it wasn't there
you know you know how your grandpa's
always like
land they may get more of it wrong like
they're definitely making more of it now
they figured out how to make more of it
do you remember that uh documentary we
saw it i think it was netflix about that
guy who built a city in the middle of
the oba city in the middle of the ocean
do you remember that seasteading
seasteading seasteading is the idea that
you can basically tie up some boats
together and it floats in international
waters but i don't think that's the what
you're talking about
no
well that structure and then it was
a city oh off italy the guy built it in
italy there's a uh there's a movie he
built a uh uh basically like a um
essentially just like a structure on
stilts and he said it was his own
sovereign nation and his own sovereign
nation off the coast of italy uh ended
up uh
he popularized it and people would drive
out there on their boats and they would
party and he was like i don't need a uh
alcohol license i have my own sovereign
nation and then he would say i was off
of spain or something what was it
definitely italy it was at a time
what's the last thing bill gates what do
we got here
bill gates posted this thing about what
advice he would give to his younger self
i'm out he said
he said i was recently asked what advice
i would give to young people who want to
make a positive impact on the world it
made me think a lot about what i would
tell my younger self wow he was a nerd
when he was in i remember this guy a lot
has changed since this photo but i
remember how excited i felt for the next
chapter my advice is simple read a lot
and discover a skill you enjoy that's
actually good advice right why i already
read a lot so i skipped so this is this
is uh this is great advice and basically
just educate yourself invest in yourself
spend time reading
right the other thing too that uh uh is
underrated in the united states of
america is some free alpha for folks you
know how many people don't have library
cards
when i was when i was a kid no when i
was a kid
i remember during the summer my mom
would take me and my brothers to the
public library
and uh i forget i think you're allowed
to take like two books or something
and uh for whatever reason i remember we
were so fascinated with the idea of like
yo you just like take them and bring
them back and like you don't have to pay
them
and and this one cost a dollar for a
library card with inflation it's like
gone through the four dollars but i
don't know what it is but yeah library
cards i feel like i don't know that many
other countries have as extensive
and robust library system as the united
states
i don't know but one guy that's really
interesting his name is brunello
cuccinelli he's like he built this
fashion empire he's italian yeah
sounds like a ball he built this massive
massive library on the campus uh for the
workers for the employees and it's all
like philosophy and the classics and
it's really cool and he was like i
really think if you have a place like
that it would make people more creative
also advice that he gives that i think
is really great he says that he reads
the same book
every decade of his life so in his 30s
he'll take something away that's
different from his 40s from his 50s
so he's brainwashing his employees
what he's selecting what information
goes in the library and they read i'm
sure
reread the classics or the books you
enjoy
do you think that uh bill gates is on
the rise or on the decline in society
who cares
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time